bonjour plaisait je comptais d'être
l'assomption bon vin kouté moi aussi je
compte en tête à l'assomption ce que si
c'est chez vous mais c'est ici que je
parle peut-être bon une journée par
semaine par deux semaines dépendamment
des activités et basse ici que je
connais le plus les jeunes et quand
c'était difficile eux ils ont toujours
aimé
ouais c'est le reste vous avez vous êtes
reconnaissants
êtes vous vous souvenez de sa wii me
rappelle que les gens d'assomption dès
la première élection de la cac qui m'ont
supporté en fait ils m'ont supporté
aussi parce qu'une partie de
l'assomption saint-gérard-majella qui
était dans mon comté de rousseau oui
quand j'étais au parti québécois et ils
sont passés du parti québécois à la cac
avec moi dès le début donc oui je suis
reconnaissant et vous avez l'âme sur le
goût tellement heureux on allait vous
regardez vendredi quand vous avez fini à
dix ans je suis fier
rien vous êtes vraiment naze une période
bénie en ce moment d'abord moi j'aime le
québec
j'aime les québécois est toujours été
passionné du québec des drapeaux du
québec
saint-jean donc d'être là premier
ministre des québécois pour moi c'est un
grand honneur
et puis un jeune belle équipe légère en
train de le découvrir pour le du plaisir
à travailler ensemble savez dans
d'autres partie par la déclencher nous y
en a pas de club que mon nom du plaisir
est-ce que pouvoir vous griser secours
parce que là vous avez beaucoup de
pouvoir un premier ministre le système
vous apercevez vous avez beaucoup de
pouvoir c'est vrai qu'on a accès à peser
sur les boutons front décide quand même
beaucoup d'argent en éducation
on peut le faire on pouvait tous décidés
à peu près on peut tout décidément même
temps c'est un pouvoir qui nous est
prêtée et les citoyens peuvent changer
d'idée on l'a vu dans les sondages vous
vous dites ça souvent rappelle toi
françois qu' il faut pas devenir
arrogant oui même si j'ai énormément de
pouvoir pique ça vaut bien je le dis à
mes ministres au moins une fois par
semaine au conseil des ministres
rester humble rester proche du monde
parce que les gens m'arrêtent sur la
route me disais ouais on est content on
sent que vous êtes comme nous au parce
que je parlais des gens qu'on va les
accueillir chez les québécois
francophones puis les sondages le monde
est très beau mais ceux qui pensent pas
comme vous il n'y a pas d'âge et de les
oublier
phalène d'horizon montréal fofana
pension mans mêmes fins faut pas oublier
majorité non plus parce que la majorité
est en manque par exemple sur le dossier
de la laïcité depuis longtemps qui ont
été ignorées le licence qu'ils sont
écoutés mais faut effectivement être
prudent et d'oser ce qu'on a eu un
projet de loi qui était très modérée il
ya du monde qui pense qu'on n'est pas
allé assez loin et qu'on aurait dû
inclure les garderies les écoles privées
mmos pour moi c'est important de
demander des compromis à tout le monde
ce que vous me dites c'est que c'était
au tour de la majorité soit si sûr vous
êtes pour calmer aussi mon jacques
pourrait s'énerver ci avait rien
ben moi je regarde ce qui arrive ce qui
est arrivé en france dont madame le pen
ce qui arrive dans beaucoup de pays les
extrémistes prennent la place pour
éviter les extrêmes font donner un peu à
la majorité donc ce que me rends pas
contre des débordements possibles
oui comme un rempart oui moi je pense
c'est la meilleure façon d'éviter les
dérapages
donc là vous avez dit prenez démarche
tuerait prenez vous avez un ami l'agent
du sol au toit
bonjour je me sens libre un bonjour ça
va bien un bon petit café
enfin enfin c'était d'en avant que ça
arrive c'est un départ n'avait sur deux
bercy comme quoi
oui on annoncé deux écoles qui vont
engendrer ici à l'assomption ce matin
c'est ça qui est important
je vous trouve solide je trouve
courageux celui de pierreville touche 8
à 18 ans on va aller en satin parler de
tous les autres sujets sur le gone a
parlé de laïcité cette dame est venue
vous féliciter en disant merci je suis
ému est ce que vous pensez
par contre que c'est vraiment derrière
nous vous allez pas être pris avec ça
pendant cinq ans d'ailleurs toujours des
gens qui vont dire qu'on a n'a pas face
et donc qu'ils vont dire qu'on ne fait
trop les débats vont se poursuivre mais
je pense que la grosse majorité des
québécois se disent enfin on a été
écouté
on va pouvoir tourner la page parler
d'éducation parler de santé parlait de
l'argent dans les poches des gens c'est
ça qui préoccupe les gens mais là depuis
une dizaine d'années
les québécois sentait pas écoutés par
leurs gouvernements
la page tournée mais vous êtes la page
est tournée il ya des contestations dans
les salles de classe on sait pas trop
comment savoir réagir
j'ai pas peur quand quand même que vous
soyez prix répondent à des questions
là-dessus
vous voulez parler d'autre chose mais on
a pris deux mesures pour éviter que ça
se prolonge
première mesure d'une clause de droit
qui faisait que concrètement il n'y a
pas personne qui va perdre son emploi
donc il y aura pas de drame la deuxième
chose qu'on a fait ça peut être discuté
c'est utiliser tes maintenant la clause
dérogatoire pour éviter que des
contestations judiciaires soient gagnés
on eu droit en vertu de la charte
canadienne d'utiliser la clause
dérogatoire pour protéger des droits
collectifs ça a déjà été fait par un bar
bourassa ça protège des poursuites ça
nous permet d'appliquer projet de loi
demandant pour les nouveaux employés
qu'est ce que vous dites aux gens qui se
sont sentis visés quand même partout
chez les femmes musulmanes des
communautés culturelles qui se sentent
visés qu'est-ce que vous quel message
vous la renvoyez à cette fin d'année ce
que je leur dis si on a pris une mesure
qui modery on aurait pu couvrir très
large rappelez-vous de l'achat des
valeurs du parti québécois on incluait
tout le réseau de la santé puis
effectivement on pourrait se demander
est ce qu'un médecin est en position
d'autorité par rapport à son patient
nous ce qu'on a choisi c'est
essentiellement gardiens de prisons
juges policiers et enseignant primaire
secondaire seulement pour les nouveaux
employés
donc ce que je dis à ces personnes là ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir se promener dans la
rue avec des signes religieux jamais
d'autres avancent il n'y aura pas
d'autres avancées donc ça veut dire
aussi qu'on met on délit mais le terrain
et parce qu'il ya des gens un peu
raciste souhaiterait qu'ils aient pas de
signes religieux ne parle même pas sur
la place publique
même pas dans des emplois où on n'est
pas une autorité ce pôle cols dont celle
en majorité la grande 99% des cas les
gens vont pouvoir continuer à porter un
signe religieux
l'autre gros morceau c'était
l'immigration ce que vous voulez des
gens qui viennent ici
et plus des diplômes puis des super
diplôme vous voulez des journaliers des
commis vous voulez des jobs moins
payantes entre guillemets noms qui
viennent de l'étranger
non on veut des jobs payant mon voeu des
jobs qui répondent aux besoins des
entreprises actuellement il ya un
système de points quand quelqu'un avait
un doctorat
ben il y avait plus de points ici a pas
de docteur est moins de points ne se
pose et qui répondait aux besoins des
entreprises
sa mission trouver chauffeur de taxi car
dr luis e 59 % des nouveaux arrivants
étaient surqualifiés sont surqualifiés
power
nous ce qu'on dit maintenant il va y
avoir que déjà cent mille personnes qui
ont déposé leur candidature dans le
nouveau programme à rima et lorsqu'on va
dire aux entreprises si une entreprise
de beauce qui veut trop soudeur mais ils
vont pour aller choisir puis nous on va
les faire passer devant tout le monde
donc on va répondre aux besoins des
entreprises dans chaque région du québec
pour les à tout le monde à montréal
ce qui n'était pas idéal pour
l'intégration plus facile d'intégrer en
région bon mais les gens qui ont été
intégrés à montréal qui sont ici qui ont
des jobs peut-être dont les dossistes se
sont retrouvés un peu dans une craque
est ce que vous le redis aujourd'hui
qu'ils ne seront pas d'envoyer les gens
qui se sont déjà intégrés sur les fameux
18000 d'aussi et qui représentait 50
mille personnes ce qu'on dit il y en
avait près 3500 qui sont déjà au québec
on va traiter en priorité
s'ils répondent aux besoins des
entreprises puis même on va peut-être
plus flexible pour ces gens alors on
vaut être humain on va s'occuper d'abord
de ces personnes là qu'est ce qu'elle
répète votre test des valeurs parce que
c'est une condition rattaché à la
résidence permanente qui est donnée par
le fédéral une fédérale il vous a pas du
tout repos dit oui là dessus ce que vous
abandonnez ce non pas du tout on a prévu
dans le projet de loi qui est adoptée
samedi qui pourrait y avoir des
conditions qui pourraient être données
dans les trois premières années puis on
veut faire deux tests on veut d'abord
qu'est la réussite d'un test français
puis la réussite d'un test de valeur
pourquoi ben pour être certain que
pendant les trois premières années les
gens qui sont arrivés qu'ils sont trouvé
un emploi qui ont été bien accueillis
qui ont eu gratuitement des cours de
français ben on joué le jeu et au
toucher mais comment pouvait imposer
cette condition là s'il fédéral veut pas
baisser le fédéral
ouais c'est vrai c'est quoi plein match
d'abord il ya une élection ça vous fait
dire à gilles vu que le parti
conservateur était ou va avoir ce genre
de conditions
monsieur trudeau est fermée complètement
trudeau pour le test de français est
actuellement un test de français ou
d'anglais exact pour les valeurs mais un
test de connaissance du canada qui
reçoit semble pas mal à ce qu'on ferait
comme test des valeurs donc on a des
discussions sur le go parle au sein des
directions confédérales commence avec
cette rue 12 mais ce n'est pas les
dossiers sur le dos aussi le choix des
juges à la cour suprême
je vais lui parler d'ici la fin de la
semaine on a obtenu la possibilité
d'avoir notre comité qui va refaire des
recommandations proposées qui volent et
suit mais au moins c'est nous qui allons
proposer des noms donc ça c'est la
première chose il ya des dossiers qui
sont réglés la formation de la main
d'oeuvre ont réussi à obtenir plus
d'argent
il reste deux aussi du tram ou de québec
à régler chaque on approche une
conclusion hockey est donc bon il
respiration en compensation pour les
réfugiés qui arrivent on n'a pas le
montant qu'on voudrait avoir meilleur
montant sur la table qui est offert par
le gouvernement fédéral donc moi je
pense quand même que ça avance les
discussions l'élection arrive
est ce que dans le fond vous n'êtes pas
plus près si on parle des valeurs
justement de monsieur chien comme
monsieur trudeau ça n'est pas laide
aussi sous prenait 2 aussi de là les
adultes de pétrole les deux hôtes à
monsieur trudeau pour ce chien sont
ouverts à ce qui est un tueur un aller
au dessus sur le territoire québécois
alors que les québécois aient aucune
acceptabilité sociale donc on a un
problème avec les deux leur rapport
d'impôt ine monsieur chier d'accord un
rapport d'impôt qui serait gérée par le
gouvernement du québec un seul rapport
d'impôt monsieur trudeau à part aux
pertes d'emplois donc bon il ya
l'immigration ou le lieu du travail à
faire
avec les deux pour qu'on soit capable
d'avoir nos deux tests français et
valeur puis d'être capable aussi
d'augmenter le pourcentage d'immigrants
dans la section économique actuellement
il ya seulement 60% des migrants qui
sont des migrants économiques et en os
40%
c'est des réunifications familiales et
réfugiés puis là je commence à par l'ado
premiers ministres de provinces la
plupart des provinces aimerait augmenter
de 60% et là dessus vous dites que
monsieur et plus entre guillemets
palabres chante certaine ouverture il ya
comme un petit lubin vous avez vu avec
les premiers ministres de la ve est un
peu dans le cloud mais pas tout à fait
ben il y avait le projet de loi c soit
129 où on ne demande finalement qui est
juste une évaluation environnementale au
lieu de deux pour réduire la
bureaucratie
nous on voudrait que ce soit le québec
mais dans le code du pipeline belle on
s'entend pas sur ce dossier-là monsanto
ça devrait - lot l'autorisation
environnementale
mais bref la campagne qui arrive cet
automne et allez vous êtes tenté une
fois ou temps en temps dans un mail et
présidera j'aime bien ce que michel
propose ce que vous allez tenter de
jouer l'un contre l'autre avec la barre
j'ai été très clair il ya aucun député
aucun employé qui doit participer à
l'élection fédérale d'entendre est
partout au québec
donc personne qui va appuyer des
candidats qui se présentent à l'élection
fédérale
maintenant je vais faire des demandes je
suis écouté les réponses via les
québécois vont écouter les réponses
aussi donc c'est important c'est une
bonne occasion de faire des demandes
puis d'obtenir ce qu'on soit sûr le goùt
debock j'ai eu l'honneur d'animer vous
avez répondu vers la fin que si le
dossier sur lequel vous mettiez votre
siège en jeu c'était les maternelles 4
ans les enfants être plus précoce quand
même bien le temps de savoir déceler les
problèmes commencent à voir d'aussi
maternelle quatre ans parce qu'on a
l'impression d'avancer reculées ça coûte
dix fois plus cher
est ce que vous voulez toujours l'offrir
à tous les québécois où vous dites les
cps possible de regarder les enfants de
4 ans au québec il y en a 30 % des
enfants de 4 ans qui vont dans les cpe
il y en a seulement 8% qui vont dans les
maternelles 80-70 que 62 % des enfants
de 4 ans qui sont ni dans les cpe ni
dans les maternelles 4 1 on a un enfant
sur quatre que des difficultés
d'apprentissage puis idéalement devra
avoir un enseignant un orthophoniste un
orthopédagogue des équipes qu'on trouve
dans nos écoles primaires mouche
convaincu que si avec la maternelle 4 1
on ajoute des ressources qu'on est
capable d'aider chaque enfant que des
difficultés d'apprentissage
actuellement la majorité obtient une
pâte diplôme mais la majorité aurait le
potentiel d'avoir un diplôme sont avec
la maternelle quatre ans on va augmenter
les taux de diplomation de façon
considérable
donc vous n'avez absolument pas changé
pas du tout d'avenue et de vision là
dessus pas du tout vous êtes tous et
déterminée elle offrira tous les
québécois oui la seule chose qu'on sait
pas c'est qu'elle % terre des parents
vont accepter
est ce que il y aura 25 % des enfants
pardon dans les maternelles quatre ans
50% 75%
quand on ouvre à lait maternel 5 1 il y
avait des gens qui disent pas si
beaucoup trop aujourd'hui c'est toujours
pas obligatoire puis à 99 % des parents
qui choisissent la maternelle 5 ans dont
on ne sait pas le pourcentage de parents
choisiront la maternelle 4 1 mais avoue
être disponible donc tous les enfants
donc je n'ai pas bien c'est vous
attendons pas du tout vous continuez
santé madame bécane peut-être qu'on est
le système de santé avait besoin de
bulldozers marqué à l'époque parce que
pour brasser les choses là elle arrive
avec une finesse qui remarqué par
plusieurs
est-ce que par contre la fameuse
promesse du 90 minutes dans une salle
d'urgence
vous allez être capable oui ce qu'on
l'oublierait opposeront l'oubli repop
est ce que ça suppose c'est que les
personnes qui vont à l'urgence c'est
juste les cas urgents
actuellement il ya la moitié des
personnes dans les urgences qui aurait
dit soigner en première ligne soit par
un médecin
soit par une infirmière ça en quelques
mois maintenant tu es capable de faire
une entente avec le collège des médecins
pour qu'on délègue des actes aux
infirmières entre autres parce qu'on
appelle les i ps et on est en train de
négocier avec la fédération des médecins
de famille omnipraticiens pour modifier
le mode de rémunération pour trouver les
inactifs à prendre en charge voire plus
de monde oui bon puis ça vous pensez que
vous êtes content des progrès réalisés
parce que ça va être dans les détails
qu'on va du coup à l'est du gers est
conscient qu'à écouter avec monsieur
barrette c'était comme fermer
l'actuellement je sens à la fédération
donc le syndicat des omnipraticiens
disent que donc continuellement et
danielle mccann et moi je confirme qu'on
voit arriver un nouvel enfant les
spéciales et je n'en parlais plus vous y
est effrayant milliard de trop fini non
non c'est toujours très vrai ce côté des
propos m
madame mais cantreau dans l'embarras sa
voiture les responsabilités du président
du conseil du trésor
donc on s'est entendu avec la fédération
des médecins spécialistes faire une
étude comparative
on a des chiffres préliminaires qui nous
montrent qu'effectivement les médecins
spécialistes au québec gagne plus que
ceux de l'ontario ce cas aucun bon sens
parce que tout le monde est dans le sens
contraire et qu'un montant ok d'environ
pas vous n'avez pas oublié ça du tout
certaine les cotisations difficile avec
le trésor sur le gouda deux courtes
question terminèrent air transat
bon vous vous dites air canada ces
québécois d'une certaine façon si tu
continues à dire ce serait une
transaction québécois eux-mêmes ce coup
de jean toronto garder les trois
acheteurs les plus probables d'air
transat a trop compagne est rien
il y en a une qui est à calgary une
quête à toronto puis en qui je dirais tu
à 70 75 % à montréal
le président d'air canada habite à
montréal il utilise un grand bureau
d'avoir comme montréal et 70 75 % des
hauts dirigeants
les vice présidents sont à montréal donc
si je prends les trous aux compagnies
aériennes
celle qu'il est plus québécois c'est
sûrement air canada meilleur scénario
maintenant c'est le moins pire
- c'est moins pire oui enfin pourquoi
air transat toit pour voler de ses
propres ailes
air canada a démarré une nouvelle
division qui ont appelé rouge
et puis on copie la cédule d'air transat
et puis c'est une compétition féroce
guerre qui fait que les profits d'air
transat sont pas les rats est bon il
reste westjet peace and we qui offre des
vols puis quand on voyage par exemple en
france d'ailleurs france de la compagnie
qui parle de nos côtés est bon faut
espérer par contre air canada câble plus
d'emplois de haut niveau puis moi
j'aimerais qu'ils gardent un peu de lui
c'est parce qu'il transat ces bleus
canado c'est oui les couleurs est
important que vous avez reporté parce
que avec des pilotes de québec car j'ai
démarré à transat avec des partenaires
et puis à l'époque québécois qui avait
le bleu avec une main le cul sur la cub
a été remplacé par un tank canadien en
rouge et saint et pâques salah
psychologique là ça vous ferait de la
peine qu'on savait faire la peine de pu
voir deux blocs de pu voir le logo d'air
transat qui est un peu comme note bb le
groupe qui avons pas sa sueur legault
c'est le teint jours des vacances où
j'allais en prendre sûrement avez vous
des projets qu'est ce que vous faites
c'est et oui bon on a réservé à la fin
juillet une semaine dans un hôtel des
cantons de l'est puis le cherche une
autre semaine avec mon épouse
probablement aussi au québec une région
mais bon un peu plus retirés prendre le
temps de se reposer avec tous les deux
et on se souhaite pas trop de bâillon
pour les prochaines cessions non plus
effectivement c'est une des choses que
j'ai demandé est-ce montjalin barre est
maintenant qu'il réglisse et gamme ainsi
de revoir le fonctionnement de
l'assemblée nationale il ya beaucoup de
perte de temps c'est ça qui fait qu'on
est obligé d'enlever des bâillons
faudrait être plus efficace sur le go
merci merci beaucoup monsieur howard k